είναι πιο όριμι οιο κατασταλαγμένοι οι νέοι έφυβοι που ασχολούνται με τον ανθελητισμό και εδώ
με τον την ευκαιρία να συγχαρό και τους ο λιπιαστους ολιμπιακούς που είχαμε τους συγκεκριμένους
δεκαπέντε και τρεις αθελιτές δεκαπέντει και οι τρεις τον παραολυμπιακν και για το ήθος τους
και για το τί μας πρόσφερα τούτα τα παιδιά βγήκαν από το εκπαιδευτικό μα σύστημα
μιλώντας μαζί τους παίρνο ιδές α τους έχουν σαν πρώτυπατα παιδιά μας να μην έχουν
ςπρώτυπα μόνον τραγουδίστες και οιθοποιούς και αλλους να έχουν ως πρότυπο νς πούμε το μάριο
γεοργίου τον μιλαντραέκοβοι θιοποίοι ήταν στο εκπαιδευτικό σύστημα βίωσαν εκφοβισμόν βίως αντην αποτυχίαν ή τον
κοντίδι θα μπρούστάνα τους πω όλους οι οποί είχαν ατυχίες είχαν δυσκολίες παρόλα αυτά πάλεψαν
και τα κατάφερα αυτό είνα αντεράστιο μήνυμα για τα παιδι είτε είναι αθελητές είτε όχι
στις ζωή μας στα έχουμε να τουχίες θα έχουμε νποτυχίες αλλά αυτά να μας γίνονται
μάθημα για να γενομα στε τπιολαμέρος παπάρα πολ πά κάποτε πάω και τώρα ως υπουργός
πά πιαμταστηρίζεταιτάξε αυτό δεν είναι δεν είμαικαθόλου φανατικοί αλλά οι ιωμάδα μου είναι το αποέλδεν
το κρίβο γιατί από πολύ μικρί και ο πατέρας μου οικογένια μου ήταν σεαυτόν το
χώρο και το πιο σημαντικό εκτς από την πάρκ καιρίνιας γιατί εκαταγόμαστε έναγοκί στο από
έλεπεξα εγώ εβο λέει θυμίζω αυτόςδε τα χρόνια περίπου αρα ναι ν εναι ιομάδα μου
στηρίζωγλές όμως τις ωμάδες είναι και υπουργός για των ανθελητισμό κυρίος αυτό που λέμε τον
γνα θελετισμό βέβαια και τον αμπορεί να πάει οικογένεια πιαστο γύπεδο νακόμα και για το
ποδόσφερο να ξεφύγουμε από τη δήποτε το ξυκό και κλείνοντας ποιο μήνημαθελι να στείλε υπουργός
παιδίας στους νέους γιατί